Norman Osborn's maybe pulling the
strings behind J jonah Jameson's daily
Google net just like he did in the video
game with his podcasts just the fact I
think he's gotta be controlling all the
media actually think this is the same
exact JJJ from the Sam Raimi universe
not knowing that he's actually in the
MCU now theory JJ Jameson is webbing the
spider-verse even more tightly to catch
himself a couple flies with JK Simmons
confirming he filmed a mystery scene for
an upcoming film mystery just because
you know we don't know what it is so all
unknowns are mysteries here indie rock
stars and we got the scoop I'm Erik
Bosse going rogue remotely with me today
are off-screen and now increasingly on
screen producers that cuddle stood
welcome back hello Erik great to see you
remotely we only live a few miles apart
but we only connect to be a computer
screen now now I'm gonna stay my friend
shout out bills mafia who sent me this
Jersey and I'm excited to be here Oh
excited to have you back also with us is
newcomer college humor comedian and a
good bud from my past and hopefully
present and future sketch team sketch
comedy live theater work just good
Clemmons thank you for joining us today
yeah I'm super excited any time to talk
about JK Simmons I am on top of it and
also I likes a shout out to my family
[Laughter]
you just put up that picture for this
show there's no the symmetry is all off
now also very excited to have you with
us a youtuber with all the nerdy scoops
I that you can find on YouTube
mr. a cosmic Warren Thompson thank you
for joining us hey it's an absolute
pleasure to be here this is awesome i
watch you guys look up to you guys this
is just fantastic I'm super excited if
we're doing shout outs thank you to
christopher Rosser ease in my editor he
works with me a lot on my channel and so
the real rejects for introducing us
awesome guys oh those guys are awesome
would we be without the real rejects and
you know where would we be without
editors John don't do any sass talk
alright let's let's dive into it JK
Simmons said in an interview this week
that he has already filmed another
appearance as J jonah Jameson and folks
we knew this was coming JK didn't just
jump spider verses from the Raimi movies
to the MCU for a simple one and done far
from home post credit cameo know there
is a plan for this Infowars madman to
bridge the spider purse together so I
asked my panel I want you to pitch me
your theory for this mystery scene or
subplot that JK Simmons has filmed what
movie isn't gonna be in how will J jonah
Jameson tie into the plot and how did he
get from the Raimi verse into the the
MCU or spunk cos bump seemed is we don't
really know how to say its sworn you
want to jump in absolutely
so okay I think that ultimately the next
Avengers in-game level event is going to
end with Avengers secret Wars battle
world and that's where all of the
different multiverses all the different
universes combine into one so I think
that after Avengers in game this has
already started to happen I think after
the snap and people have come back I
think people came back to their own
universes and I actually think this is
the same exact JJJ from the Sam Raimi
universe not knowing that he's actually
in the MCU now and SPU MC now I think
that the coincidence that Sam Raimi is
directing Doctor Strange and the
multiverse of madness now and the fact
that in his original trilogy he
mentioned Doctor Strange is I don't
think it's that much of a coincidence I
think this is planned I think ultimately
this is going to lead up to Tobey
Maguire spider-man and Tom Hollands
spider-man meeting each other because I
think Toby's spider-man gets pulled back
to with MJ but he realizes hey there's a
new spider-man in this universe I can
stop being spider-man I can finally take
a step back I can finally be with my
wife and I can live a normal life but
then when everything starts kind of
going to hell and phase 4 he realizes I
can't sit back anymore I have to go then
he goes and sees Doctor Strange and then
ultimately leads back to moment where
the classic mean that we all love and he
sees
they go and that's what we get that is
that's that's awesome so you're thinking
this could be a scene maybe a
post-credits scene for multiverse of
madness just get Raimi to take care of
this because no one knows how to work
with JK Simmons like Sam Raimi yeah yeah
I think so I think I think we're in for
either like you said either a
post-credits scene or you know like a
small little cameo that's just
explaining that other things have
happened in the universe's but now
they're all kind of forming into one and
that could be like just the tip off the
end of Doctor Strange - right I I love
that Warren and I love that we're
already starting off super rogue like
here I came in there thinking that we
were just gonna do it oh it's gonna be
you know just something at the end of
denim let there be car danger or Morbius
places that could go on their own
pretty Road pretty crazy and Warren
comes in guns a-blazing with multiverse
action we're not even doing on the sunny
side of things we're just going straight
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe with
Sam Raimi give him him the keys and
Kevin Tobey Maguire a lot of acting to
do which yeah well as I as I issued as
an edict last week we are doing the
scoring differently normally you are
awarded Rogi points for your theory all
of you are starting with ten rookie
points that is your starting point
that's your allowance for this and I
will deduct
Rogi points based off of the gripes that
I have with your theories so we're an
overall I very much like your theory and
anything with multiverse in there you
know I in Game four however I must
adduct one Rogi Sparkle buck before this
idea that Sam Raimi somehow in back in
the early 2000s predicted that there
would be a Marvel Cinematic Universe and
slipped in the Tucker trades are taken
line package notes movies just in the
off chance or baby away they'll come
back and maybe yeah maybe he looked
ahead in the future this is one out of
14 million 605 future he's he's like
just in case I'm gonna put in case Scott
Derrickson wants to put the devil in the
movie and Kevin Feige he's like oh no
China's not gonna distribute a movie
with the devil in it and then he gets
fired
they're like let's bring in Sam Raymond
into it hey it worked out but just a
little bit too much with stretching you
lose one but you still have no journey
though yes I think that's there all
right who is next
I can go next okay so what I think JK
Simmons doing when he comes in playing
triple j so I think which is it's so
hard now I'm moving into Warren's and be
like who I agree with Paul I believe
that was a nod to the PlayStation 4
video game I think that he is gonna make
a small cameo appearance just like he
did in the video game with his podcast
just the fact I think he's gonna be
controlling all the media and I think by
controlling all the media I think he's
just gonna be featured on like third by
okay so this is what I'm gonna say I
think that it's gonna when it starts
with like his revealing who Peter Parker
is I think he's going to go straight to
the Daily Bugle and be like oh it could
be honestly out of his garage we don't
know because he sounds like in that clip
that is like he's kinda mimicking
Infowars it could be anywhere yeah we
could be anywhere right now but I do
think that it will come with him running
straight - straight to Triple J and
being like why did you do that why did
you help me like that and he's just like
your men I don't like you I never liked
you I never liked you before but I do
think he's gonna be the same Triple J
that sam raimi made I think it's just
because it you can tell also by the
stinger
he'll awful Adair he's aging so it's
just like if they bring this it inspired
him and the newer spider-man the firemen
to read out there far from all that I
think they would be in because I think
that they would still put him in the
same world I think he don't be that and
I think because he's like aging and we
see that aging I think so as technology
and so now instead of doing like
newspapers on digital trying to make and
enforce title booth and just coffee mad
crap about a Cyberman I think it will be
just small cameos but it'll be like
after that interaction it'll be when
he's like saving someone swinging down
and hears it in the car and let's go or
when he's running through a kitchen
obviously could we lower the kitchen
running and the chefs are listening
through it in the background
that's where I think JK Simmons okay
yeah I love that Jessica and I love like
going right to those closing moments at
the end of far from home because like
it's kind of like how Incredibles to
opened right in that final battle with
the Underminer like yeah why not like
he's in the middle of Manhattan
everyone's just gonna look up at that
light pole and be like hey southern
tourists who's there cuz ya know to
avoid Penn Station yeah Penn State to
walk around if they you don't have to
but ya know so like yeah let's start
right there and just see him swing over
to the Daily Bugle or try to find you
know triangulate where this guy's
broadcasting from to stop that because
just having JK Simmons in whatever
garage he's in being pervasive that's
like the biggest kind of threat right
like his podcast you cannot stop that
once it goes out to the airwaves
like how much is he recorded already cuz
you know we bank content like crazy on
this show we got thousands of hours of
content that we could just drop out
there if you if you try to censor us
YouTube we're gonna find you cannot but
I think that is like the most fun way I
do unfortunately Jessica have to deduct
one point from you because this idea of
he's aging what's that deliberate or was
that just JK Simmons getting older they
told him to age on purpose wait you
think that was a wig dyed his hair and
closed it up like JK Simmons has been
totally bald for like 30 years
are you saying the yellow mmm where
didn't I have to shave his head and that
Santa Claus commercial I don't believe
it
my mind was just blown well you know
what Jessica for that because I might
have blown and I didn't expect that you
get your your point back I'm giving you
your all right Zack what have you what
have you got um okay so my theory is in
like obviously everybody's made the like
the new JK Simmons jenna jameson like
alex jones connection right Infowars
which by the way how none of us done the
spin fo but but i even want to go to
like somebody adjacent to that harvey
from TMZ right i think there's a chance
cuz like I don't think Alex Jones has
never broken a story right he's not even
pretending to be a reporter unless you
consider the gay frogs a story that
whereas like you know Harvey and TMZ
like mmm they actually like they're the
first people to report about Kobe
Bryant's dad and like they're on the
fries she breaks some really big stories
especially now that everything is on a
cell phone camera right and they kind of
buy up all the footage right whether
you're buying from Quentin Beck Mysterio
or somebody you know some kid you know
some thirteen-year-old with his iPhone
um and so I think that is kind of gonna
be the role he plays with kind of like
Jessica said like showing up in little
vignettes on TV screens maybe like you
know as reported by in in
you know on computers or something like
that but I think we're also going to
discover that kind of like you know Alex
Jones in real life Julian Assange in
real life even these people that claim
to be about like telling the truth have
their own agendas and often those in
agendas are like interlinked with making
money right Alex Jones is like the
aliens and the the Illuminati whatever
buy my vitamins right like I think
that's a Jay jonah Jameson is gonna be
like right he's sure he's trying to you
know he has like an anti spider-man
agenda he's always had that right but he
also is trying to make a buck not only
through getting views getting more
attention for his website but also he's
being paid off okay and this is I think
the important part this starts to come
out maybe in a post-credits scene in
Morbius gets fleshed out in venom - let
there be carnage but I think we're gonna
get the SPU emcees first big bad and I
think it's gonna be Norman Osborn of
Oscorp okay
shout out to my buddy on patreon the
discord ruby who kind of inspired this
idea right that Norman Osborn is maybe
pulling the strings behind Jay jonah
Jameson's daily Google net right like
you know cementing his reporting to the
anti spider-man and all of this because
he's already developing this anti
spider-man agenda that we'll build over
the course of like all of these
spider-man adjacent movies awesome I
love that idea of Norman Osborn or
Oscorp being behind it you know when we
rewatched ant-man the wasp there was
that whole like back story with Sonny
Burgess character and he's like I have
my buyers they're very opinionated or my
buyers are very selective people like we
never found that out which is crazy -
they never answered but I guess it
didn't matter that story but like yeah I
think there is going to be some kind of
like big new financial industry
especially Stark Industries is still
around but there's gonna be some big new
arms dealer competitor and I see Oscorp
filling that void and I know that's the
MCU versus this boom see but you know
Michael Keaton in both we don't really
know where that border is I do love that
idea of like who is funding JK Simmons
like because it seems like there is a
it's between The Daily Bugle net versus
like the Daily Bugle print maybe you
just bought that domain name early and
yeah yeah he could be the kind of the
media arm the marketing division of
Oscorp to like destabilize the world is
very cool
you lose a point then I'm just gonna
give to Ruby because Ruby also helps
there no no co-author no Ruby that's the
ruby colored sparkle and that's that's
that's in the Ruby Bank right
also I love Eric since the last time I
was on this show and and I I have to
think this is a direct reaction to when
I host the show and I'm the biggest
softie I give everybody all the points
all the time but this is now you
course-correcting from all the mistakes
I've made
yes that's right I am I'm the Robin Hood
I'm stealing from one I'm stealing from
people who have nothing I'm stealing you
have to become an indentured servant it
I will keep a record I have a notebook
and I'm gonna say what you have to work
off it with future Theory you uooo uooo
Eric 5 Batman Theory's Jessica already
has 10 you can't possibly have more than
10 there attends a limit you can't gain
more than because I don't have more and
it's Zach you mentioned Ruby's theory
this is because every week we play rogue
theory with our patrons on new rock
stars discord and we actually we didn't
know we're gonna be talking about this
last week when we gave this to our
patrons to to talk about but yeah they
all came up with some really great JK
Simmons Jay jonah Jameson theories for
where he's gonna appear next Ruby
mentioned Norman Osborn which I think
was a really great theory Connor had
some great ideas where Eddie Brock was
working with Jake with Jay jonah Jameson
but really the winner of our discord
challenge was moon Pantalone who yeah
and with this a really fun theory that
explains why Jay jonah Jameson outed
Peter Parker in far from home that there
was like a story behind that and
basically he
breaking the sinister six out of prison
and at the end of this theory this is
where I think makes it the the true
rogue theory he gets turned into a
vampire by Morbius and he is hunted down
and that movies post-credits scene by
blade which any way you can get Marissa
le is bleeding what'd you guys think of
that there I know Zack you you
definitely saw it yeah I loved it
I also loved any theory that is like
legally and financially impossible let
that happen but I don't care that's what
I love I love it when you go [ __ ] yes
yes anytime you put blade in something
on it yeah that's why I like it it's so
wild but like I'm like yeah that that
should happen not it could happen it
should happen I like that that's a
certain ah Dakota for sure now for all
of you watching you can play this - you
can have your Theory read on a future
episode of rogue Theory just might be
coming to patron of new rock stars and
join in our discord if you want to join
this discord community you got to become
a patron it's one of the things that
keeps keeps the lights on in our garage
or bunker or whatever undisclosed
location we are shooting from so let us
now move on to some people who helped
make this episode possible thank you to
our sponsorship station if you are an
e-commerce seller right now is a wild
time and shipstation is here to help
when we've tried to ship things in the
past like a new rock stars merchant can
get confusing figuring out what has
shipped what hasn't and where it's stuck
in the delivery process how much it all
costs while shipstation clears all that
aprea helps online sellers of any size
get orders out quickly save money on
shipping costs and then keep customers
happy they'll get you the shipping rates
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies it's the fastest easiest and
most affordable way to manage and ship
your orders just a few clicks and you
will be managing your orders printing
out labels and getting your product to
happy customers shipstation makes it
easy they work with all the major
carriers like UPS and FedEx and their
interface brings your products together
whether you're selling them on Etsy
Amazon or your own website shipstation
is the number one
for online sellers you'll [ __ ] more in
less time with the best rates available
and right now you can try shipstation
for three for sixty days when to use our
offer code rogue make sure your business
is ready to meet the demands of delivery
culture get started at shipstation comm
today click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in rogue that
ship station calm and use the offer code
rogue ship station comm make ship happen
we also want to think keeps for a help
in sponsor this episode two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're
thirty-five and losing your hair can be
a bummer
we have keeps it's easier more
affordable to get the treatment for your
hair loss and help you keep the hair
that you have already keeps offers
generic versions of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy and you don't have to go to the
doctor's office you can do it all from
home you meet with a doctor online and
they ship the treatment right to your
home
find out why keep says more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors in
nearly 100,000 men trust keeps for their
loss prevention medication if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss just go to keep PSICOM slash rogue
theory to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's ke e PS comm
slash rogue theory alright on to our
next topic
folks we heard reports this week that
michael keaton is in talks to play an
older bruce wayne figure maybe in the
upcoming flash movie and you can add
this to rumors that jeffrey dean morgan
could be reprising thomas wayne from
Batman V Superman and a possible
flashpoint Thomas Wayne Batman bro look
there's a lot of reports and stuff out
there I broke it all down in another
video doesn't mean that like we're not
getting another Batman because the whole
point of flashpoint is like there's
alternate universes and a multiverse
coming together you can get all your
Batman if you want them in this movie
it's possible but I wanted to ask you
guys assuming that you know flash will
be opening up the DC movies to DC
Multiverse with past Batman and Batman
villains what other surprise cameo from
past movies would you like to see in
this movie oh personally personally I
wanted to see
let the breeze come back to play the
role wait okay so let's dig in this you
think you want Arnold Schwarzenegger
Governor Arnold Schwarzenegger to go
bald
your turn frosty blue with lots of nice
freeze puns and just a quick cameo or do
you want them to live in this
refrigerator for like you know a subplot
of movie why I want I want them to be in
the movie I want them to play all the
character in the movie and I know what
people are thinking they're like please
no but I'm like no I need this I would
rather that than a cameo I think I'm
like show up in stuff like he'll keep
making Terminator movies this guy's got
time on his hands
we've got Expendables like twelve by now
he loved being nostalgic so I feel like
we could easily pick this to him and be
like come on play this role it's very
good Jessica Clemens really well Jessica
Clemens I will have to deduct two just
because I am cold as ice when it comes
to this slide like ice out of an ice
tray oh yeah that's that's that's clever
that was clever so you get one of them
back you get one back we still lose what
recovery still lose one all right who's
next who else should we see in this
flash multiverse of the DC world I would
just really really love to see the
Riddler Jim Carrey Batman Forever I
would love to see him come back I feel
like he's done a lot right now
he's ageless like we kind of talked
about the guy doesn't age I feel like
you could just come in I feel like the
Riddler almost is Jim Carrey in like
real life just really just kind of out
there but I'd love to see him come back
and just be like riddle me this riddle
me that and batma turns around who's
afraid of the big black
I think it would just be so awesome and
I think at the end of Batman Forever
he's like I can't die kill you it would
be awesome if he's like I couldn't kill
the other one but I could kill you
something like the multiverse and
something like that you know so I would
enjoy that you know what we really just
need its we need to visit the Arkham
Asylum of like the Burton and shoemaker
Batman movies so you can just slip in a
lot of these guys because like we were
talking about for the the episode like I
accidentally quote Jim Carrey's Riddler
all the time just like Oh what people
ask me if I remember something I
whispered myself just like that version
of him in his like prison garb where
he's like he's cosplaying as Batman
that's the version of him what I don't
need green jumpsuit with with orange
crazy hair Riddler I need that kind of
lessels on his face yeah maybe he can be
like fantasizing that but really we cut
to him and he's like in his cold like
which is not humane treatment at all
that's like a 19th century pre-reform
haunted Asylum that's not a way no one's
getting mentally healthy in those places
that's a holder guy okay uh Warren were
you gold I think you were gold you know
what I will deduct too - you wear blue
you always had me you know what you're
loosing three now for trying to trick
the host you lose three see what you're
doing all right Zach okay
chairman Voss thank you for calling on
me I'll just bring up this point real
quick let it be known both Warren's pick
and Jessica's pick those two villains
were not in Michael Keaton movies okay
boom whereas the person I want to bring
back the character and the actor were I
want to bring back Michelle Pfeiffer's
cat one
okay okay she has said over the years
she still thinks back fondly on the role
not the costume there lies with the role
in general right she's you know I've
been like interviewed about it or quoted
like she had great stuff to say about
zoe kravitz getting casted the batman is
the role and like but she looks back
finally on it and she's like oh I'd love
to be Catwoman again someday or
something like that and we know she's
down for superhero movies recently
I mean appearing in an ant-man in the
wasp right as get at him so that that
also gives us just like Michael Keaton
now exists in the DCU
and the MCU as would Michelle Pfeiffer
is different characters right it also
makes it kind of an in-universe sense i
think it was at least alluded to in the
timbre and Batman's that not only did
she survive Batman Returns we saw her
like at the end like looking at the the
bat symbol in the sky but like you know
there's a romantic relationship there I
think even it's kind of Canon like
Robert wolves reporter character I think
either in the Catwoman movie or like
maybe in the air overs crossover nted
that like she ended up with Bruce Wayne
right they married and we're together
yeah so like maybe this same you know
Michael Keaton Bruce Wayne this is like
she's got to live happily ever after
with him right and she's kind of his
badass like also fighting you know wife
figure okay I want I want Michelle
Pfeiffer
so maybe however Michael Caine is gonna
show up is this kind of older mentor who
might be from an alternate universe I
think his partner is Michelle Pfeiffer's
Catwoman okay Zach I can see that I
could see it especially with Michael
Keaton coming evolve if Michelle
Pfeiffer Selina Kyle was just there you
know feeding some cats in the background
that seems to be the most plausible and
the most interested like I we don't I
don't think anybody once like to stitch
Michelle Pfeiffer back in that costume
which they had to stitch her into it it
was so unpleasant for her no well in the
same way poor Michael Keaton doesn't
want to be in the no movement yeah right
however Zac I will have to deduct some
points I have to because you tried to
butter me up into the game I
saying thank you for calling on me
chairman vodka I am NOT chairman I am
boy king Eric was a boy king boy came
and you're losing one you're you also
called her Janet PIM and she's Janet Van
Dyne my friend she did not take her
husband's name
she's Janet Van Dyne they are partners
they are progressive especially for the
80s 1987 I need your time to stick with
your maiden name yes she did so and hope
they had died she took her mother's name
out of hatred for her senile father
whose crazy crazy in the mg so you lose
another one
but you get to keep the rest those are
mighty those are my grapes because
otherwise scenic I'll yeah we need to
see more in there okay folks we have now
arrived at our final round road
questions based off of my math Jessica
you have nine remaining Warren you have
six remaining and off screen producers
IQ of seven remaining yes all things can
change with your if you have terrible
questions that I've gripes over I will
do that so quicken much it'll make your
head spin all right locomotion number
one the duffer brothers teased this week
that the next season of stranger things
will have a couple celebrity cameos from
the 80s who do we most want to see show
up and stranger things forward I really
want to see who I think would be so
iconic for the 80s
Christian Slater hear me out he's iconic
for the 80s and he loves doing like
roles that are like in this realm he
loves coming back too and also we want
to Heather's reunion for an 80s icon I
think Christian flavors like number one
for me yeah I could see that okay well I
mean so many ideas came up and I was
like oh we know at least part of the
season set in Russia so I was like Yakov
Smirnoff seems like from Canada though
the dumpers were also quoted as saying
it was great to meet their heroes and I
don't know of anybody
identifying Yakov Smirnoff as their hero
but I do think certainly a hero the
duffer brothers and like so fitting for
a movie that's all about like 80s
nostalgia I'm gonna say Steven Spielberg
that's yes Spielberg's great getting you
think actually the actual director
Steven Spielberg is someone who plays 80
Spielberg oh well I was gonna say real
Spielberg but not as himself just as
like you know a hotdog stand
vendor or something like yeah yeah sark
enthusiasts all right Warren who do you
think um so my dad loved classic 80s
movies he made me watch a ton and I
would just absolutely love to see either
Bill Murray or Steve Martin I love those
guys I think they're hilarious I think I
think 80 is when I think of them all of
their movies sergeant bilko stripes
movies like that I just think they're so
good and they're just such iconic people
I don't know if you'd have somebody
played the like younger versions of them
or you just have them cameo in there I'm
not sure which way you go but I think
seeing them would just be like that's
that's good you know guys I'm trying to
think I think in all of your situations
like because stranger thinks is so
reference II all of your people like
exist in that universe so like they they
love Ghostbusters they went cosplaying
as ghostbusters I think in stranger
things season two or three Yakov
Smirnoff gets referenced like when they
talk to the Russian guy obviously
Spielberg does because they have like
Jaws posters so like it'd be crazy to
have like characters who are who exist
in that world
like they're also the actors come in
yeah it'd be like a crazy like a Danny
Glover in maverick moment where they you
know they look at each other that's a
crazy crossover in all time we all
remember maverick yeah yeah alright
we're a question to mark hamill recently
revealed that he has had secret vo
cameos in every Star Wars movie besides
the prequels I actually included a droid
bartender in the Mandalorian where would
we be most surprised to find a Mark
Hamill voiceover cameo
oh I chose oh but I'd be surprised to
see you man but I also wasn't kind of be
that surprised I beg oh yeah they're
good at getting good people is Steven
universe oh yeah so what would that what
would that look like so I think okay so
like in Steven universe how they have
Nicki Minaj play like a mixture of when
amethyst and garnet combined together I
think this one would be lapis lazuli who
is that
like for people that don't know Steven
universe she's kind of a sadder
character I think her makes him a
paradoxes a more technical computer
skilled character one day used together
I think that would be mark hamill good I
love it all right who's next I think I
would be most surprised if he shows up
in doc McStuffins as like a like a troll
doll come to life but that sounds
exactly like the Batman animated series
Joker loved it I thought the question
was I thought we were looking for his
actual secret cameos because he said
like he does the voiceovers in every
episode he does them in each film but
the prequels is what he said there's a
secret voice over in each one so sorry
that's what I thought we were talking
about did you do homework did you find
Mark Hamill
I don't know if I found it it's very
tricky because he went he said look for
scenes with Patrick Williams and then
it's actually a pseudonym like he
doesn't exist so you're like oh so I
tried to do as much research as I can
and what I thought it would be cool for
him to be voice over is the stormtrooper
tr-8r and it's in the force awakens it's
the storm trooper who Finn fights when
Finn as the lightsaber writer I think it
would be cool though sin because you
know he's Luke Skywalker
he's like the Jedi he brought balance to
the force and he's like the good guy
that he could you know do a voice over
he said and you know stunt double doing
the fighting but I just that little
thing I looked at a few other things I'm
just like I don't know who he is but I
think it would be cool if you like
played an evil stormtrooper calling him
a traitor yeah uh Warren for going to
the lengths of trying to hide Easter
eggs I think I have to deduct points
from the other two just for not going I
think we lose a blue and I think Zack
loses a point as well so things are
getting even
Erik Erik you have no idea how many doc
mcstuffins episodes I watched as
research okay I don't know all right on
to our third and final road question
Joel Schumacher passed away this week
our IPS the director of many films
including Batman Forever and well the
little love Batman Robin
that featured arnold schwarzenegger
history as jessica well knows and you
know of course mr. freeze delivered the
best assortment of awful cold puns and
your best arnold voice i would like you
to give me a mr. freeze cold pun let's
get some ice okay III wrote it I wrote
an original here for this okay so it's
like mr. freeze has like you know he's
got his like freeze ray or whatever on
Batman he's about to pull the trigger to
kill him and he's like you could have
saved the money by coming on Tuesday cuz
I give violence free on Tuesday free on
distri okay you know what it's it's hard
to write it's hard to write good ones
you have to see it written down okay
pretend around 1:00 okay so he's got you
know he's got his freeze ray on Batman
he's about to kill him and Batman says
like boy how cold are you and and mr.
freeze goes I'm measured temperature in
degrees Kelvin
[Music]
instead of Kelly oh I would have never
known that he says do you know what
killed the day before the Ice Age but I
liked it a lot because I was like it is
it is a crazy one and I think because
zach is the only one who did come up
with such original ones he did do a lot
of work for this I'm deducting points
for him from Jessica and from Warren on
that but because that didn't know when
to stop he's all
so I believe our final scores are off
screen producer Zack has five points
the cosmic Warren has five points and
Jessica Clemens has seven points making
you our winner of today's episode of
road theory congratulations Jessica do
you have a wish that you would like to
request from us yeah oh my gosh yes and
I thought about it and I want everyone
to say happy birthday to me and their
best impression of the Riddler like I
need like a little bit of sack on it
it's not my birthday
riddle me this riddle me that
what Day falls on January 10th your
birthday happy birthday Jessica you want
to hear the most annoying sound in the
universe might be the wrong so for your
birthday message imagine that you have a
big birthday cake being carted in but
there's like just a rubber slit to right
in the middle of it so I'm gonna come
out well that's it for this episode of
rogue theory wanted to give a big thanks
to Oliver grip are all of our guest
off-screen producers that Carlston
thanks for having me
cosmic Warren anything you want to shout
out my friend um No thank you to
everybody who supported my channel thus
far my friends my family especially they
helped me come a long way and again huge
fan of new rock stars love you guys so
absolute honor being on the show yeah
we're big fans of you too man and be
sure to subscribe to to cosmic cosmic
ward on YouTube information on your
screen that's a great Channel lots of
great stuff there and of course our
winner today Jessica Clemens
congratulations and thanks for coming
dodge yeah of course
thank you I've done some really fun
sketch work and plays with with Jessica
so glad you could get on this show
Oh any time you want to talk like this
and don't forget to subscribe to rogue
theory on wherever you get your podcast
stay tuned to the YouTube channel for
this and other shows you can follow me
on instagram @ EA boss follow me rock
stars guys see you next week
[Music]